estimando seno de 0.4 usando un
polinomio de maclaurin cuál es el grado
más pequeño del polinomio que nos
asegura que el error es menor a una
milésima entonces qué es lo que estamos
diciendo por acá
bueno pues podríamos tener una función f
de x y aproximarla con un polinomio de
maclaurin de grado n o de una forma más
general también podríamos aproximarlo
con un polinomio de taylor ahora en este
ejercicio este es un polinomio de
mclaren sin embargo esta aproximación no
va a ser perfecta vamos a tener un
residuo el residuo de la aproximación
del polinomio de grado n y por supuesto
este residuo depende de en qué x estemos
evaluando a la función ahora si queremos
utilizar la información específica de
este ejercicio
fx esceno de x ok aquí tenemos la
función seno
y la queremos aproximar cuando x es
igual a 0.4 y esto va a ser igual al
polinomio de mack loring de grado n
evaluado en 0.4 más el residuo de ese
polinomio de grado n también evaluado en
0.4 y lo que realmente queremos hacer en
este ejercicio es averiguar cuál n es la
más chica que nos asegura que este
residuo sea menor a una milésima
nosotros queremos saber cuál es la m más
pequeña cual es la n más pequeña con la
que
con la que el residuo de nuestro
polinomio de grado n evaluado en 0.4 es
menor que una milésima osea 0.001 y ésta
es simplemente otra forma de reescribir
este problema pero para resolverlo
podemos utilizarla cota del error de
lagrange que también es conocido como el
teorema del residuo de taylor
hemos demostrado este teorema en algún
otro vídeo pero lo vamos a volver a
escribir por acá tal vez no va a quedar
tan claro al principio pero todo va a
quedar más claro
conforme resolvamos este ejercicio el
teorema del residuo de taylor o sea la
cota del residuo de lagrange nos dice
que si la derivada n 1 de nuestra
función está acotada por m si la
derivada n 1 de nuestra función si su
valor absoluto es menor o igual que
alguna constante m para todos los
valores de x en algún intervalo abierto
en algún intervalo abierto que contenga
el centro de nuestro polinomio de taylor
que como este es un polinomio de mack
loring ese centro es 0 y a la equis que
nos interesa que en este caso es 0.4
pero aquí le vamos a poner y a x
entonces si esto es cierto si la
derivada n 1 de la función f está
acotada o sea si su valor absoluto es
menor o igual que m en algún intervalo
abierto que contenga a 0 que si estamos
hablando del caso general
esto es c y a la equis que nos interesa
lo que nos dice el teorema del residuo
de taylor también conocido como la cota
del error de lagrange nos dice que si
esto es cierto entonces el residuo del
polinomio de grado
está acotado y es menor o igual que esta
cota m por equis elevada a la n 1 / n 1
factorial tomando su valor absoluto ok
esta es la cota del error de lagrange
pero como lo vamos a aplicar para
resolver este problema
bueno pues podemos empezar por pensar en
la derivada n 1 de nuestra función
así es que pensemos y podemos acotar la
bueno pues la derivada de seno es coseno
pero luego la derivada de kosheh no es
menos seno y así nos seguimos entonces
todas estas derivadas van a ser o senos
y cosenos pero la ventaja que tenemos
aquí es que tanto el seno como el cose
no están acotados por uno así es que no
importa cuántas veces derivamos a seno
su enésima derivada siempre va a ser
menor o igual que uno así es que para
esta función en particular
esta f de x que en realidad es el seno
de x
el valor absoluto de la derivada n 1 de
s
efe x siempre va a ser menor o igual que
1 pero esto es cierto sólo porque fx es
seno de x y por cierto esto es cierto
para cualquier valor de x no solo en
algún intervalo entonces este es nuestro
valor de m el seno y todas sus derivadas
están acotadas por 1 así es que ya
tenemos la m la cota por lo que ya
podemos utilizar la cota del error de
lagrange que nos dice que el error del
polinomio de grado n evaluado en 0.4
aquí nosotros sabemos que la equis en la
que nosotros queremos acotar al error es
0.4
no necesitamos minimizar la n para un x
en general sino para el valor que nos
interesa el valor absoluto del residuo
del polinomio viene en 0.4 es menor o
igual que
m pero m en este caso es 1 por lo cual
ni siquiera lo tengo que escribir y
luego por equis que es 0.4 elevado a la
potencia n 1 a la n 1 y luego dividimos
entre n 1 factorial ok y esta es la cota
del error de lagrange si logramos
encontrar alguna forma de que esta cota
sea menor a 0.001 entonces habremos
acotado nuestro error a menos de una
milésima pero ahora como encontramos una
n que haga que esta cota sea menor a una
milésima y como vamos a encontrar esa n
bueno pues podemos probar con algunas en
es ir aumentando el tamaño de n hasta
que encontremos alguna n que haga que
esto sí se cumpla y es justo lo que
vamos a hacer y vamos a hacerlo en forma
de tabla aquí vamos a ponerlas en next
por acá vamos a poner la cota que es
0.4 elevado a la n 1 / n 1 factorial
bueno podemos empezar con n igual a 1
cuando n es igual a 1 aquí tenemos 0.4
al cuadrado entre 2 factorial lo cual es
igual a 0.16 entre 2 lo cual es igual a
0.08 que definitivamente no es más
pequeño que una milésima entonces vamos
con la siguiente n n igualados
cuando n es igual a dos tenemos 0.4 al
cubo entre 3 factorial lo cual es igual
a cero punto 0 64 y aunque lo escribí
demasiado rápido pero estamos dividiendo
entre 3 factorial que es 6 ahora si lo
analizamos con cuidado esta división se
parece mucho a 0.01 que definitivamente
no es menor que una milésima por lo que
tenemos que irnos a la siguiente
en 3 y nos queda 0.4 elevado a la n 1
que es 4 entre 4 factorial que es igual
0.0 256 entre 24 y haciendo las cuentas
de esta división esto es un poquito más
grande que 0.001 un poquito más grande
por lo que yo presiento que la siguiente
n si va a ser que la cota sea menor que
una milésima a ver veamos tenemos 0.4
elevado a la 5 entre 5 factorial y esto
es igual a cero punto cero
el 24 entre 5 factorial que es 120 y
ahora sí si hacemos esta división
podemos ver que esto si es menor que
0.001 esto definitivamente es menor que
una milésima así es que podemos concluir
que para el polinomio de grado 4 el
residuo evaluado en la equis que nos
interesa que es 0.4 si es menor o igual
que una milésima y listo ya resolvimos
este ejercicio 4 es el grado más pequeño
del polinomio de mclaren que nos asegura
que el error sea menor que una milésima